تركت جنى ترامب الزوجه السابقه للرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تركت وراءها
ثلاثه اطفال
و34 مليون دولار مقسمه بين عده اصول وكلبا
بعد وفاتها في يوليو الماضي وفق مجله فورس
التي كشفت ان الثروه ستقسم بين اطفال
ايفانا كما تركت عقارين لاصدقاء لها وحاول
ترك عقار اخر لزوجها السابق لكنه توفي قبل
لها لم يحصل رئيس الامريكي الذي شارك في
تشييعها على شيء من الشركه وتقول فورد ان
ابرز الاصول في ملكيه ايفانا هو منزل
مستقل في مدينه نيويورك يقع على بعد نصف
مربع سكني من سنتر بارك ويحاول ورثتها
حاليا بيعه ويطالبون ب 26.5 مليون دولار
ثمنا له هذا وتركه ايفانا ايضا بحسبورد
جميع ملابس على الصليب الاحمر الامريكي مع
استثناء الملابس المصنوعه من الفاروق التي
واشهد ببيعها مع هذا العائدات الى اطفالها
الثلاثه
[موسيقى]